c'est l'une pereira dos santos vous êtes
professeur de mathématiques mais ce que
vous pouvez vous présenter un tout petit
peu plus oui bonjour je suis enseignante
au collège les molières aux
essarts-le-roi et j'enseigne cette année
à des élèves de 3e et de 5e
voilà alors depuis lundi vous est
confiné sur ordre de la présidence
quel est votre quotidien c'est de très
longues journées de travail avec de
nombreuses heures passées derrière
l'écran d'ordinateur à vrai dire je suis
étonnée moi-même de la fatigue que ça
représente et du temps passé pour
préparer ces petites séquences de coin
en fait je réalise qu'on saigne à
distance bassa s'improvise pas du tout
découpez les cours en petit diaporama
avec des commentaires explicatifs
préparer des exercices leur correction
mettre tout ça en ligne ça prend
énormément de temps
d'ailleurs j'ai dû revoir un petit peu
mes exigences à la baisse en terme de
contenu parce que je me suis rendu
compte en voyant ce que font mes enfants
que ce que je donnais c'était peut-être
un petit peu trop
donc voilà on improvise on tâtonne on
essaye de s'améliorer mais c'est vrai
que c'est beaucoup de travail et
beaucoup de temps passé est-ce que vos
élèves sont réceptifs sont présents
derrière leur écran d'ordinateur pour
suivre ces séquences alors en fait moi
j'ai choisi de ne pas utiliser de
logiciel qui ne respectent pas les lois
de protection des données et qu'ils
utiliseraient des fichiers avec des
numéros d'élèves des e-mails d'élèves
donc j'utilise uniquement preneur car un
logiciel de cahiers de textes classiques
et puis ent environnement numérique de
travail donc je vais pas de contact
direct avec eux mais par contre je leur
ai donné mon email professionnelle et
donc certains d'entre eux m'ont envoyé
des messages avec par exemple des photos
de leurs copies ou bien des questions
précises sur le court
donc j'ai gardé contact avec certains
d'entre eux mais pour d'autres banon
fait la communication est remplie
j'avais demandé en troisième un petit
travail à me rendre
dit il ya quand même deux ou trois
élèves qui n'ont pas qu'ils n'ont pas
rendu le travail donc voilà je réagis en
ignore les causes et c'est parce qu'ils
n'ont pas de l'ordinateur à la maison ce
qui est possible
ça vous inquiète un peu justement et de
leur côté être d'inquiétude au c alors
évidemment il ya s'inquiète aussi parce
que ce sont les élèves les plus fragiles
qui risquent d'être pénalisés par ce
système d'enseignement à distance en
classe on a un échange continu elle avec
des questions même ne serait-ce que par
des échanges de regards on voit quels
sont les élèves qui sont perdus donc à
ce moment là on est attentif on leur
pose des questions on les interroge pour
essayer de comprendre ce qu'il va pas là
évidemment tout ça ça n'existe pas donc
moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est sur la durée
en fait merci beaucoup c'est une pereira
dos santos
je vous remercie